สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูสวัสดีครับ
วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 7
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้
วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
9 โมง
9 โมงกี่นาที
9 โมง 35 นาทีค่ะ
ค่ะ 9 โมง 35 นาทีวันนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น
นอนกี่โมงคะ
วันนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะตื่นนอน 11 โมงค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
วันนี้ 9 โมง
แล้วครูฟ้าตื่นนอน 11 โมง
ขอโทษ
นะยังไม่ตื่นเหรอคะ
ยังค่ะ
มันก็ประมาณ 5 ชั่วโมงแล้ว
ตื่นเช้ามาก
ผู้หญิงง่วงนอนน้ำตาไหลเลยนะคะเนี่ย
ตื่นตี 4 นะคะ
ก็ 9 โมง 35 แล้วแล้วครูหญิงเนี่ย
นอนหรือยังคะ
ตอนนี้เนี่ย
22:00 นแล้ว
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงก็ง่วงเหมือนกันแต่ว่าทำอะไร
ครูหญิงต้องทำงานไงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เนี่ย
คุณหญิงไม่ได้อยู่ประเทศไทยแต่
ที่อเมริกาตอนนี้ครูหญิงอยู่อเมริกาใช่
ไหมคะที่อเมริกาเป็นเวลากลางคืนแต่ครู
หญิงทำงานเนี่ยสอนภาษาไทยเนี่ยนักเรียน
เนี่ยเรียนเนี่ยเวลาประเทศไทยถ้าอเมริกา
กลางคืนประเทศไทยเนี่ยตรงข้ามกันก็เป็น
เวลากลางวัน
กลางวัน
ครูหญิงก็เลย 4 ทุ่มเนี่ยนอนไม่ได้ค่ะแต่
ก็
ง่วงนอนนะก็เลยพอก็เลยคิดว่าจะมาคุยกับ
ครูฟ้าว่าถ้าเราเนี่ย
ง่วงนอน
ง่วงนอนเนี่ยนะคะเราจะทำยังไง
เราจะแก้ง่วง
นอนเนี่ยทำยังไงดี
ถ้าเราง่วงนอน
ทำยังไง
นอน
ถ้าเราง่วงนอนก็คือให้เราเนี่ยนอนไปเลย
ใช่ไหม
เดินเตียงนอนเป็นยังไงคะเนี่ยเดินไปที่
เตียงแล้วก็นอน
ไม่ได้ค่ะถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยง่วงนอนแล้วก็
เดิน
ต๊อกแต๊กต๊อกแต๊กไปที่เตียงเตียงอยู่ตรง
นี้เองนะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงอยู่แค่นี้เองนะคะ
เดินไปแล้วก็นอนเนี่ยไม่ได้ไงถ้าคุณหญิง
ทำได้ครูหญิงก็ไม่ถามครูฟาเพราะว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยตอนกลางคืน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ค่อยนอนไงก็เลยคิดว่าครู
ฟ้าน่าจะเก่งเกี่ยวกับทำยังไงให้ไม่ง่วง
นอน
ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ถ้าง่วงนอนทุกครั้งนะคะผู้หญิงก็จะดื่ม
กาแฟอันนี้กาแฟหรือเปล่า
กาแฟสิคะ
มันจะมีอะไร
ดูเหมือน
ดูเหมือนโกโก้
ก็เลยไม่ค่อยรู้นะคะเนี่ยอ้าวครูฟ้าต้อง
ดื่มกาแฟแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าง่วงนอนเนี่ยกูฟ้า
หาวเนี่ย
ถ้าโดยปกติ
คุณครูฟ้า
ถ้าโดยปกติใช่ไหมผู้หญิงน่ะทำงานเมื่อ
ก่อนทำงาน 10 โมงเช้าอย่างนี้ 10 โมงเช้า
หรือว่าทำงาน 9 โมงเช้าตอนเช้าเนี่ยทำงาน
ทำงานแล้วก็ถ้าซักบ่ายโมง
รู้สึกว่าแบบง่วงนอนแต่ต้องทำงานผู้หญิง
ก็จะดื่มกาแฟ
ตอนเช้าเนี่ยอาจจะดื่มกาแฟแล้ว
แก้วที่ 1
แก้วที่ 1 เนี่ยดื่มหมดแล้ว
พอตอนบ่ายรู้สึกง่วงนอนอีกก็จะดื่มกาแฟ
แก้วที่ 2
มันจะแก้ง่วงจะทำให้เราเนี่ยตื่นแล้วก็ทำ
งานได้แต่ว่าตอนนี้
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดื่มกาแฟแล้วไม่ตื่นหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะเพราะครูฟ้าไม่ดื่มกาแฟค่ะนัก
เรียนใช่ครูฟ้าไม่ดื่มกาแฟไงแต่ผู้หญิง
เนี่ยช่างง่วงนอนก็จะดื่มกาแฟพอดื่มกาแฟ
ก็จะตื่นแต่ว่าตอนเนี้ยเป็นเวลากลางคืน
ถ้าผู้หญิงง่วงนอนแล้ว
ประมาณ 4 ทุ่ม
40 นาทีเนี่ยนะคะดื่มกาแฟตอนนี้ก็คือคืน
นี้แหละ
ไม่ใช่แค่ตื่นแล้วนะคะไม่นอน
ผู้หญิงจะนอนไม่ได้เหรอคะ
ไม่ได้แล้วไงเออก็เลยแบบว่าเออบางครั้ง
ถ้าเราทำงานตอนกลางคืนเราอยากให้ตื่น
เนี่ยนะคะกาแฟก็อาจจะใช้ไม่ได้หรือว่าบาง
คนเนี่ยบางคนเขาเขาอาจจะไม่ได้ง่วงนอน
เหมือนผู้หญิงไงแต่เขาเขาอาจจะแบบง่วงนอน
ตอนที่ขับรถอ่ะค่ะ
เวลาขับรถ
อันนี้ไม่ได้นะคะนักเรียน
ใช่
โดนๆนะ
อาจจะขับรถซัก 6 ชั่วโมง
ถ้าเราอยากจะอยู่เราอยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหม
อยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็อยากจะไปเชียงใหม่
อย่างเงี้ย
แต่ไม่อยากนั่งเครื่องบิน
ก็จะขับรถขับรถขับรถขับรถขับรถแล้วก็อาจ
จะเบรกนอนแล้วนอนแล้วก็ตื่นอีก 1 วันแล้ว
ก็ขับรถแต่บางทีขับรถ 6 ชั่วโมงขับรถ 3
ชั่วโมงอย่างนี้ค่ะถ้าง่วงนอนแล้วก็ขับรถ
เนี่ยมันไม่โอเคใช่ไหมแล้วจะทำยังไงเนี่ย
ให้ไม่ง่วงนอนถ้าต้องขับรถ
ดมยาดม
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะลองเสิร์ชนะคะนักเรียนว่า
ในนี้มียาดมไหม
ไม่ใช่ยาดมนะ
คะมียาดมยาดมมันจะเป็นเหมือนยูคาลิปตัส
[เพลง]
ยูคาลิปตัสเลยนะคะ
ดมยาดมเนี่ยก็จะทำให้เราตื่นหรอคะ
ทำให้เราตื่นนะคะเพราะว่า
เหมือนยาดมมันมีมิ้นมียูคาลิปตัสอย่าง
เงี้ยมันทำให้เราแบบว่า
เขาเรียกว่าสดชื่นคือมันจะ
สดชื่นคือมันตื่นนะคะนักเรียนมัน Bright
อะไรอย่างนี้คือสดชื่นหรือถ้าดมแล้วไม่
ตื่นนักเรียนก็ป้ายตา
แล้วเอาตรงไหนอ่ะเอาตรงนี้ใช่ไหมเพราะว่า
ยาดมเนี่ยมันจะเป็นส่วนนี้ที่เอาไว้ดมนะ
คะแล้วก็อีกฝั่งนึงเนี่ยมันจะเป็นน้ำก็
เอาน้ำเนี่ยหยดใส่มือแล้วก็ทาตา
ขับรถแล้วก็มองไม่เห็นพอดีเลย
เออจะได้ไม่ตื่นเอ้ยจะได้ไม่หาย
หลับ
ไม่นอนหลับ
แต่ว่า
กินของเปรี้ยวๆได้ไหมอย่างเช่นมะนาว
ได้สิ
แต่ไม่เอามะนาวนะ
มะนาวไม่ได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวตาไม่โอเคมะนาวเนี่ย
มันเปรี้ยวก็เอามะนาวอาจจะไม่ต้องบีบนะคะ
เนี่ยมีมะนาวที่เขาหั่นไว้แล้วแบบนี้ใช่
ไหมเราก็หยิบมะนาวแล้วก็เข้าปากแล้วก็
เคี้ยว
เวลาที่เรากินอะไรเปรี้ยวๆเนี่ย
เขาจะทำให้เราตื่นเหมือนกัน
ก็ดีสิกินอะไรเปรี้ยวๆใช่ไหมหรือว่าถ้า
ไม่มีมะนาว
ลูกอมได้ไหม
อมลูกอม
ลูกอมก็ได้นะ
คะ
นี่แบบนี้
ลูกอมมาอยู่กับมะนาวมะนาวเล็กๆหน่อยนะลูก
อมแบบนี้ก็ได้เนาะแต่ต้องอาจจะเป็นลูกอม
เปรี้ยวๆแบบลูกอมรสมะนาวลูกอมลูกอมรส
เลม่อนลูกอมรสส้มอย่างนี้รสส้มใช่ไหมคะ
ลูกอมรสส้มที่มันแบบจะเปรี้ยวๆนิดหน่อย
เนี่ยมันก็จะทำให้เราเนี่ยตื่นแล้วก็ไม่
ง่วงนอนไม่ว่าเราจะขับรถหรือว่าเรียน
หนังสือถ้าครูฟ้าเข้าคลาสเรียนภาษาอังกฤษ
ใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าเรียนภาษาอังกฤษอ่ะแล้วง่วง
นอน
ด้านในกระเป๋าภูฟ้าน่าจะไม่มีมะนาวอยู่ใน
กระเป๋าใช่ค่ะ
หรือว่าเลมอนใช่ไหมเลม่อนเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าอาจจะมีลูกอมไหมอยู่ในกระเป๋า
ลูกอมมีแน่นอนค่ะครูฟ้าชอบลูกอมนะคะนัก
เรียน
ใช่ไหมคะไม่อยากง่วงนอนก็จะอมลูกอม
หรือว่าเคี้ยวหมากฝรั่งได้ไหมอ่ะถ้าเรา
ง่วงนอนน่ะ
คิดว่าฝรั่งก็น่าจะได้นะ
อันนี้นะคะนักเรียนอันนี้คือ
หมากฝรั่งนะคะเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนนะเมื่อ
ก่อนนะคะ
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยตอนเมื่อก่อนตอนครูหญิง
เนี่ยนั่งรถทัวร์
อันนี้มันเป็นรถทัวร์นะ
รถทัวร์
กรุงเทพฯ
จากกรุงเทพฯนะคะแล้วก็กลับบ้านที่ชลบุรี
บางครั้งช่วงสงกรานต์น่ะวันที่ 13 ถึงวัน
ที่ 15 เมษายน
มากๆแล้วค่ะสงกรานต์อย่างนี้รถก็จะต้อง
วิ่งเยอะๆคนที่เขาขับรถทัวร์น้องเขาจะ
นั่งประมาณตรงนี้ใช่ไหมเนี่ยคนที่เขาขับ
ค่ะขับรถทัวร์บางครั้งเนี่ย
ใช่เข้าที่เขาต้องขับทั้งแบบกลางวัน
ขับกลางคืนอย่างนี้ค่ะแล้วบางทีเรานั่ง
ตอนแบบบ่ายสองโมงอย่างเงี้ยคนขับเนี่ยเขา
ก็ขับแล้วก็มีแอร์เย็นๆแล้วก็ขับไปบาง
ครั้งเนี่ยเขาก็ง่วงนอนก็เคยมีอันนี้ผู้
หญิงนั่งใช่ไหมผู้หญิงไปคนเดียวแล้วก็มี
ผู้หญิง 1 คนนะคะเขาก็บอกคนขับรถทัวร์ว่า
ให้เคี้ยวหมากฝรั่ง
[เพลง]
ใต้เคี้ยวเนี่ยมีหมากฝรั่งแล้วก็เคี้ยว
เพราะว่าเวลาเคี้ยวๆเนี่ยเราจะต้องรู้ใช่
ไหมคะถ้าเราเนี่ยเคี้ยว
เคี้ยวอะไรในปากเนี่ยเราก็จะรู้แล้วหมาก
ฝรั่งมันก็จะมีรสชาติใช่ไหมอาจจะเป็นรส
มะนาวรสมิ้นท์รสสตอเบอรี่อย่างนี้มันก็ทำ
ให้เราเนี่ยตื่นคนขับก็จะขับรถได้
ไม่ใช่แล้วก็เคี้ยวไปด้วยเป่าลูกโป่งหมาก
ฝรั่งไปด้วยผู้หญิงคะถ้าเป่าลูกโป่งแล้ว
มันใหญ่
ใหญ่
ที่หน้านี่ก็คือ
ไม่ใช่ง่วงแล้วนะคะมองไม่เห็นทาง
คิดว่ามีอะไรอีกไหมที่จะช่วยให้เราเนี่ย
ไม่ง่วงนอนตื่นนอกจากเคี้ยวหมากฝรั่งกิน
ลูกอมกินของเปรี้ยวๆดื่มกาแฟแต่ถ้าขับรถ
นะดื่มกาแฟเยอะๆก็จะปวดท้องนะคะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ฟังเพลง
ฟังเพลงก็จะทำให้เราตื่นไม่ง่วงนอน
ใช่ค่ะฟังเพลงค่ะต้องฟังเพลงแบบไหนอ่ะถ้า
เราฟังเพลงเปียโนเพลง Acoustic
Mozart
แบบนั้นน่าจะง่วงนะคะนักเรียน
[เพลง]
ต้องฟังเพลงแบบเพลงร็อคไหม
เสียงดังๆค่ะต้องฟังเพลงแบบเสียงดังๆนะคะ
จะได้ไม่หลับ
แล้วก็อีกเรื่องนึงที่คุยอยู่รู้สึกว่า
ฟังเหมือนกัน
แล้วไม่หลับไม่รู้ว่าครูฟ้าจะหลับหรือ
เปล่านะก็คือฟังเรื่อง
แบดมินตันผ้าเช็ดตัว
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
ผีค่ะประเทศไทยมี
Yes
io แต่ไม่ต้องมีแต่ Ghost  Radio ก็ได้
ฟังใน YouTube ก็ได้นะคะเวลาที่เราขับรถ
แล้วก็คนไทยนะฟังเรื่องผีไปด้วยเนี่ยทำ
ให้เราตื่นนะคะเพราะว่าหนึ่งเราจะรู้สึก
กลัว 2 เนี่ยเราจะอยากรู้ถ้าเราอยากรู้
เนี่ยเราหลับเราจะไม่รู้ใช่ไหม
กลัวฟังเรื่องผีดูฟ้าคิดว่าทำให้เราตื่น
แต่
ว่าชอบฟังมากนะคะเรื่องผีอ่ะแต่น่าจะกลัว
มากจริงๆครูฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยคนไทย
ในออสเตรเลียก็ฟังเรื่องผีนะคะนักเรียน
ใช่แล้วก็หลายๆคนน่ะค่ะถ้าเขาต้องขับรถ
อ่ะที่ผู้หญิงพูดถึงอ่ะค่ะถ้าเขาต้องขับ
รถตอนกลางแบบไม่อาจจะไม่ได้เป็นตอนกลาง
คืนก็ได้อ่ะที่ต้องขับรถนานๆน่ะอาจจะต้อง
อาจจะซัก 2 ถึง 3 ชั่วโมงถ้าเขารู้สึกว่า
เขาจะง่วงแล้วไม่อยากดื่มอะไรเพราะว่ามัน
ต้องแวะเข้าห้องน้ำใช่ไหมคะเขาก็จะฟัง
เรื่องผีเนี่ยให้ตื่นไงก็เป็นเทคนิคได้นะ
คะแต่ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่าถ้านักเรียน
ง่วงนอนแล้วอยากให้ตื่นเนี่ยนักเรียนจะทำ
ยังไงก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอ
นี้นะคะอยากดูฟ้าไปก่อนเนาะให้ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเขากลับ to  the  future นะคะเนาะ
เวลานี้เราไปก่อนนะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะอันนั้นก็เรียน